the plastic is still on here
so
rtx pre-orders are apparently going
gangbusters
and i get it
some of you out there have had literally
two years to save your pennies and
frankly not a lot of exciting pc
hardware to buy in the interim
but
come on
giving away your money without seeing
any performance data is a bad way to
make purchase decisions
besides making matters worse is that the
marquee feature of the rtx series real
time ray tracing
is basically mia today
so all we're left with is how much the
geforce 20 series improves performance
over last gen in traditionally rendered
games
and
some discussion about nvidia's generally
bass ackwards approach to this launch
speaking of bass akwards not using a vpn
do you have private internet access vpn
yet if not go get it at the link below
and if you do well go get it anyway
makes a great gift
give the gift of internet security
[Music]
so before we start there's a term that
you need to understand rasterization
without getting too deep into it your
graphics card uses this technique to
turn a three-dimensional scene into a
flat 2d plane of pixel similar to a
photo many times per second
since the days of wireframe and flat
polygons we've added lighting textures
post processing and more to the pipeline
but they all still only apply to the
screen space versus the whole scene's
world space
tldr rendering a game today isn't
fundamentally different from how star
fox was rendered on the super nintendo
in 1993
ray tracing meanwhile is fundamentally
different
so it's a simulation of light
interacting with the world space acting
sort of like an eyeball in reverse
so instead of rays of light coming in
rays are actually cast out from the
camera position where your screen is and
then everything is calculated from there
the more rays you have and the more
times those rays are allowed to interact
or bounce around the scene the more
detail you get and it's a superior
method in every way to rasterization
except for one
speed
up until now ray tracing has only been
available in rendering software that can
take hours or even over a day to
complete a single frame on a high-end
workstation
so
how the heck then is nvidia pumping out
many frames per second using this tech
well the new enthusiast tier touring
architecture cards the 2080 and the 2080
ti include what they're calling rt cores
which for rtx enabled games render a
simplified ray traced scene in parallel
with the standard cuda cores raster
rendering so the result is a
traditionally rendered scene with ray
traced lighting occlusion and
reflections so that uh hybrid rendering
as nvidia calls it gives you a lot of
the benefits of ray tracing without the
massive computational cost and without
game developers needing to completely
re-engineer their game engines
and there's more the titan vs tensor
cores are back as well for geforce these
are being leveraged for nvidia's new
deep learning super sample anti-aliasing
which nvidia claims can achieve near 64x
super sampling with less performance
impact than traditional aaa which
they've achieved by pre-training data
sets for each supported game and then
pushing those results out via driver
updates
there is a catch though
just like rtx real-time ray tracing it
has to be supported on a game by game
basis
so now you know
but
knowing is only half of the battle we
also need to see it which unfortunately
is easier said than done because we
could have the most epic test benches in
the world like this one i have here in
front of me right now that i got my
finger stuck ow anyway
there are no
actual rtx games to test
so we can't very well measure its
performance versus non-rtx then can we
well we'll get back to that in a minute
first let's have a look at some normal
gaming results and
you know what
they are pretty good
all across the board the 2080 ti
averages in the high 50s or higher and
remember guys this is at 4k
ultra with the 2080 seeming to be
content with the traditional
let's meet the performance of the
previous generation ti card level of
performance frankly all of this is a
massive relief given nvidia's refusal to
talk about traditional gaming
performance in their keynote
as for productivity well we were a
little disappointed when blender refused
to run on the new cards compute
capability 7.5 doesn't have a kernel yet
but
if the rest of these results are
anything to go by it's gonna be good
because these numbers just crush the
1000 series cards and the 2080 even
manages to match amd's vega 64 in lux
ray's opencl rendering that was a huge
gap to bridge so touring gpus are going
to make really good workstation cards i
can't wait to get my hands on the quadro
versions of these guys so overall then
the 2080 performs kind of like a 1080 ti
cool and the 2080 ti performs kind of
like a titan v a much more expensive
niche product also cool
well sort of cool all this performance
comes at a cost and i'm not just talking
about the much higher price tags than
last gen now the manufacturing process
has shrunk 25 from 16 nanometer to 12
nanometer but with over 50 percent more
transistors so that means massive dies
with higher overall power draw and
thermals hence the overbuilt not to
mention extremely like shockingly heavy
twin fan vapor chamber cooler and the
beefy power delivery on the founders
edition designs this time around you
guys should let us know by the way if
you want us to dive into overclocking
these cards in a future video in the
comments below
speaking of future video
surprisingly envinc and vnc got an
update so text is now more readable and
there's less blocking than the 1080ti to
be perfectly honest to us it looks very
similar to if not better than x264 on
the fast preset so it looks like game
streamers or anyone else who relies on
high quality stream capture no longer
needs to choose between quality and
speed and there's other cool features
baked on board as well like the new vr
link connector that handles both power
and high resolution video over a single
usb type-c cable for vr headsets
alright then
so what about dlss and where are the rtx
on rtx off comparisons
well that's actually a really good
question
so battlefield 5 was delayed until late
november
shadow of the tomb raider which is out
and is an rtx title is apparently
getting the functionality added in a
post-release patch
but uh
that's that that's it then right
wrong we weren't gonna give up on you
guys that easy
so we reached out to a developer
directly with a game in the works that
supports both technologies and they
graciously agreed to come over and show
off their beta exclusively for you guys
originally they did anyway
so this is where showing off our shiny
new hardware ends
and the criticism begins
so
they were forced to bail
they couldn't give us any details but
if you want to know what i think
i think it's that nvidia and more
accurately rtx isn't ready yet
i mean
to put the rushed
last minute nature of this launch in
perspective we got our card and its
driver at around noon on friday the 14th
of september
this video goes up early in the morning
on the 19th
that is at best 2.7 working days to
evaluate the biggest graphics card
launch in two years and other
publications that we've spoken with have
confirmed that they were in a similar
boat
so
like what are they doing
is this someone high up in the chain
having an executive moment
is this them not wanting us to spend
much time
digging into these things what purpose
is served by rushing this launch i mean
the thing too to consider is that it's
not like amd has anything to compete
with the 1080 ti let alone its successor
so
i guess this is open letter to nvidia
time guys
people ordered this thing on a promise
and
yeah it's it's early days
maybe things aren't quite polished yet i
get it
but you're clearly not ready to deliver
and frankly
this is the kind of sh
that gives pc gaming a bad name shiny
badges on the sides of boxes that at
best are supported by a small handful of
games or at worst flat out don't do
anything and that's what rtx is today it
doesn't do anything
so
that's that's what i have to say guys i
can't benchmark goals i can't review
future potential
i mean honestly given your track record
rtx will probably be pretty cool
but
this whole situation is a ridiculous
self pwn here like outside of hopeless
fanboys when they buy something people
expect it to actually do what it says on
the tin or they expect to at least be
able to get a glimpse of what they're
getting that hasn't been run through
your own pr department as it stands
right now the only tangible things that
we can show our viewers which are your
customers are the very much curated
nvidia special dlss build of the final
fantasy 15 benchmark and then a couple
of ray tracing demos that tell us
nothing about the real world before and
after performance impact
i mean we can stare at them which is
like wow such excite
um
so like it looks like it works and and
maybe maybe this is what these features
will look like in actual games
but who can say for sure when we can
only test in a tightly controlled
environment
so
you're letting us run benchmarks but
you're still making it really hard to
recommend this thing for the function
that is right in the name of the product
because nobody without ads speak about
it and will cut off your balls nda
actually knows how well rtx works
so
bottom line for you the viewer then
these cards are strong performers and
that's really good both for them and for
the upcoming lower end touring cards
that won't have rt or tensor cores
but we can't
draw a real conclusion because
this review is incomplete
just like the rtx 2000 series
but you know what's not incomplete
thermal takes 20th anniversary it's like
complete which is why they're
celebrating with their level 20k series
they've got 4k styles to choose from the
vt the xt the gt and an updated version
of their triple chambered full tower
case they've all got a sleek modern
design with rounded front corners and
tempered glass they've all got ample
room for cable management and radiator
mounts for water cooling and they also
feature usb type-c connections check out
the link to get yours now at the link in
the video description check out the link
to get whatever check out the link to
get yours it's down below you know where
it is so thanks for watching guys if you
disliked this video then you can hit
that button but if it was awesome you
can hit like get subscribed or maybe
consider checking out where to buy the
stuff we featured at the link in the
video description but we're not going to
go we're not going to go full on
go buy it how much of your life do you
want to look back on and not have had
ray tracing because the reality of it is
whether you buy it today or you buy it
in two weeks it's gonna be the same
amount of time because you don't have it
yet
even if you own the hardware
anyway also linked in the description is
our merch store which has cool shirts
like this one and our community forum
which you should totally join it's like
infuriating you know
it's like it's like when you get like uh
it's like when you buy a new cpu but the
motherboard was out of stock and you're
just like
this does nothing
this does nothing until i have the rest
of the pieces